[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم متابعينا الكرام في حلقه خاصه
جدا بمناسبه الذكرى العشرين لانطلاقه قناه
العربيه الحقيقه كنا حابين انه يكون في
لنا لقاء مع الرجل وراء الكواليس مدير عام
قناه العربيه الاستاذ ممدوح المهيني اهلا
وسهلا
شكرا لك شكرا لك على الفرصه هذه شكرا لالك
يعني احنا تبادلنا الادوار هون واصبحت انت
ضيف وصاحب مكان طبعا يعني في هذه المقابله
فرصه مهمه من خلال انه نتكلم ونتناقش
مواضيع الاعلام بشكل عام والعربيه بشكل
بشكل خاص جميل من العمل والجهد والفرح
والحزن يدور وراء الكواليس ولكن مش كل
الناس وكل المتابعين بيقدروا يشوفوه على
الشاشه صحيح دايما نشوف القنوات الاخباريه
مواضيع مثيره بغض النظر العربيه او غيرها
وما يحدث داخل غرفه الاخبار دائم مواضيع
مثيره بكون سعيد لو طلعنا بعض الفائده
للمشاهدين يعرفوا بعض المعلومات بعض القصص
بعض التحديات فانا اعتقد انه يعني
ان شاء الله نطلع بشكل كويس ان شاء الله
طيب خلينا نبلش 20 عام على انطلاقه
العربيه عمر عقدين من الزمن
كتير طبعا
قنوات ظهرت وقنوات اختفت ولكن العربيه ما
زالت موجوده ما زالت موجوده بهاي القوه
وهذا الزخم وبتتوسع كمان شو هو السر والله
السر انا اعتقد ممكن في ثقافه العمل قبل
قبل العمل الصحفي نفسه العمل الصحفي هو
البضاعه اللي تبيعها في اخر النهار ولكن
داخل العربيه وهذا لاحظته من بدايه من اول
يوم انا صرت مدير قناه العربيه شغف الناس
وحرصهم على العربيه اهتمامهم يمكن تعرفين
في ناس يشتغلون عشرين ساعه متواصله في بعض
المراسلين يطلب مني يروحون اماكن خطيره
جدا واحيانا استغرب انا بديت اسال نفسي
ليش مثلا صحفي حاب يروح مكان خطير مثلا
اول ما ظهرت كيا الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
احد يروح مثلا في عز سقوط كابول يطلب مني
مراسل او مذيع انه يغطي هناك يعني احداث
كثيره بديت افكر فيها بعدين خطيره جدا
يعني خطيره جدا بعتقد انه هذا جزء من
ثقافه العمل ثقافه العمل وشغف الناس
بالمكان هذا السر النجاح في محطات كثيره
عندها ممكن تمويل اكبر عندها عدد ناس اكبر
عندها
قدرات اكبر من العربيه ولكن ما عندهم
القدر الكبير من النجاح لهذا ما استمروا
العربيه خلال عشرين سنه في نجاح مستمر
وهذا جزء من الشغف لما رجعت مع الزملاء
شفنا عدد المقابلات الكبير عدد التغطيات
عدد في زملائنا يعني يعني ماتوا بسبب ذهب
وضحايا بسبب
هالشغف
للمهنه نفسها وللمحطه بشكل بشكل اساسي انا
اعتقد هذا السر الاساسي
يعني اذا حبينا ليش العربي استمرت متالقه
طيله هذه السنوات
[موسيقى]
العربيه يعني بعديها بفتره يمكن قصيره حصل
حدث جلل في العالم كورونا كورونا انتشرت
وكانت فتره صعبه جدا على العالم اجمع وعلى
كل القطاعات وكل
المجالات لا سيما مجال الاعلام في الوقت
اللي كل الاعمال توقفت والناس قعدت
ببيوتها احنا كاعلاميين بالعكس عملنا زاد
اكيد كان في خصوصيه لاداره قناه مثل
العربيه في مثل هذه الظروف الاستثنائيه
كيف كانت التجربه والله كانت صعبه جدا انا
احيانا نذكر طبعا فتره مخيفه كانها كابوس
لانه المحطات الاخباريه عملها مختلف عن
مؤسسات او شركات او حتى مثلا محطات
الترفيه تعرفين محطات الترفيه عندهم
مسلسلات اشياء مسجله بالنسبه للعربيه ولا
تنسين عندنا محطتين العربيه والحدث مش
محطه واحده
قناه الترفيه عندهم اشياء مسجله ممكن
يسجلوا عشر ساعات عشرين سنه ما يحتاج دوام
مستمر في الاستديوهات او في مكان العمل
العربيه كان عندنا 24 ساعه سبع ايام في
الاسبوع كيف انت عندك عدد كبير الموظفين
كيف تستغني عن نص عدد الموظفين بسبب
الاجراءات الصحيه بسبب الحجر ونفس الشيء
وهذا التغني عن وجودهم في المحطه ولكن
اكيد مش راح نستغني عنهم يعني
كيف انت تعمل تعمل التوازن
فاللي عملناه واحنا نزلنا عدد الموظفين
يعني الناس يشتغلوا من منازلهم 80% فقط في
المبنى عندنا ممكن تذكرين انت عشرين فقط
وهذا على فكره تحدي صعب انت عندك
24 ساعه هواء تغطيات مستمره نفس كورونا
نفسها كانت حدث كبير كعامل صحفي لازم احنا
نكون متواجد بكل مكان فهنا صارت حقيقه وين
وين الصعوبه بالموضوع
يعني كان تحدي انا كان بالنسبه لهذه
الاساسي انه المحطه ما ينزل مستواها تحافظ
على المستوى
وهذا اللي اتمنى انه نجحت فيه اعتقد انه
احنا اجتازنا هاي المرحله الصعبه بنجاح
كبير وباقل الخسائر يعني حتى لو كان هناك
بعض الاصابات عنا في يعني اصابات كورونا
ما بين العاملين الا انه الحمد لله يعني
كانت كلها عدت على خير وقدرنا انه نكون
تغطيه العربيه الصراحه
بالنسبه لنا احنا انتبهنا للوباء من اول
شيء يعني قبل محطات اخرى
غطينا وفتحنا هوا بشكل اساسي طبعا ما
توقعنا انه بيكون وباء لمده سنتين العالم
كله يقفل وتصير في مشاكل اقتصاديه ومشاكل
سياسيه لكن يعني حسينا انه القصه غريبه من
البدايه على الفور ارسلنا مراسلين فتحنا
لايف بشكل ساعات كبيره بعدين وسعناها
تقريبا اخبار السياسيه ناس ممكن يتذكرون
اختفى تقريبا من الشارع كل اخبار اخبار
الصحيه
وكان الناس اللي ما يعرفون ذيك الفتره
عندنا مش التحديات التحديات الداخليه هذه
اللي ذكرتها قبل شوي يمكن من اهم ابرز هاي
التحديات هو موضوع اللي ظهرت وانتشرت او
الاخبار الزائفه اللي ظهرت وانتشرت بشكل
كبير في فتره كورونا هي طبعا كانت منتشره
قبل ولكن بفتره الكورونا زادت وكان لها
وقع لانه صار في بعض الاشاعات تنتشر
بارشادات خاطئه بعض الناس يعني للاسف تم
تضليلهم عن طريق هذه الاخبار كيف بتتعاطى
العربيه وغرفه الاخبار مع مثل هذا النوع
من الاخبار حتى يفرزوا الغث من السمين
والله على فكره اول اخبار الزائفه انا
اسميها وباء مثل ما كورونا وباء بالنسبه
لنا احنا الصحفيين الاخبار الزائفه
القصه القصه على فكره الاخبار الزائفه مش
يعني مش قصه جديده قصه قديمه قصه من
القرون الوسط انا اتذكر
في القرون الوسطى مثلا كانوا
مع بدايات انتشار الالات الطابع وانتشار
الكتب يعني سابقا كان في الحكايه الشعبيه
والاشعار على فكره الاخبار الزائفه قديمه
جدا كان ينشروا اخبار وشائعات
ويستهدفوا شخصيات معينه بالتظليل حتى
[موسيقى]
كثير نساء بالسحر
اعدمت الاف النساء بسبع اخبار الزائفه لان
الاخبار الزائفه هي افكار بالنهايه تؤثر
على افعال الناس يتخذوا قرارات غلط وعلى
حياتهم وبعدين تطورت الفكره الى ما بدانا
في يسمونه الثوره الرقميه والثوره
وتكنولوجيه يعني سابقا يعني قبل ثلاثه
عقود او اربع عقود عندنا مصادر محدوده
للمعرفه او للاخبار التلفزيونات والصحف من
السهل ان الشخص يتحقق اذا معلومه غلط او
معلومه صحيحه
مع انتشار الثوره الرقميه صار العمليه
صعبه جدا على ايش الاخبار اللي اللي احنا
بنستهلكها او على الاقل بتمر علينا عن
طريق السوشيال ميديا مهوله كيف يمكن
التحقق من كل هذه الاخبار هو صعب الصراحه
يعني
تقريبا
الان عند الناس سبعه ايام بالاسبوع 24
ساعه اخبار معلومات معلومات
سابقا الشخص كان يقدر يتحقق اذا كان في
عدد معلومات محدود محدوده يعني الان من
الصعب عشان كذا طبيعه الناس
تحول الانسان من الشخص اللي تحقق ويتاكد
وصار عنده ما عنده قدره ففعلا صار صعب
للقدره انه يتحقق من الاشياء هذه عشان كذا
الناس تحول لو لاحظتن تحول اللي هو سلوك
الناس من لوحه الايجابي الى الشخص السلبي
صار يتقبل المعلومات ويصدق كل شيء ويصدق
قبل فتره قرات احصائيه انه 60 تقريبا
بالمئه من المعلومات الموجوده
بالسوشيال ميديا او بشكل عام اما معلومات
يعني غير معروف مصدرها قد تكون صحيحه بس
مش معروف المصدر او معلومات زائفه مشكله
كبيره مشكله كبيره
حنا وجهناه لموضوع
الموضوع الكوفيد كان هدفنا الاساسي اللي
هو نقل معلومات صحيحه وموثوقه للناس هذا
هدفنا الاساسي استمعنا في غرفه الاخبار
قلنا جاسم مع الزملاء كيف يا جماعه هذا
موضوع حساس موضوع في حياه او موت لازم حنا
نكون دقيقتين جدا ما يطلع طبيب الا طبيب
موثوق ما نطلع معلومه بالاخبار الا معلومه
موثوقه لانه ممكن شخص يشوفك وياخذ معلومات
غلط
وتتسبب لا سمح الله باذيه لانه خصوصا في
موضوع كورونا كان يعني اي خبر بيطلع بمس
حياتنا بشكل مباشر وصحتنا ولما يكون في
بعض الارشادات الخاطئه هذه ممكن تؤدي الى
نتيجه عكسيه وخطيره جدا جميل الاستاذ انك
ذكرت موضوع السوشيال ميديا والثوره
الرقميه اللي صارت الثوره الرقميه هاي زي
كل شيء جديد مع انها بطلت جديده هلا ولكن
كل شيء يدخل الى الساحه بالفتره الاخيره
في الها مدار وفي الها منافع
بالنسبه
للسوشيال ميديا او مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الثوره الرقميه هاي كيف اثرت
على العربيه بشكل خاص وعلى الاعلام
التقليدي كما نعرفه بشكل عام بس هو
استكمال الجواب قبل شوي موضع مرتبط ونفس
الجواب على على سؤالك هذا هو مثلا احنا
قررنا انه تكون اخبار موثوقه ارسلنا
مراسلين عملنا تغطيات قابلنا اطباء كان
هدفنا الاساسي انه نكافح الاخبار المزيفه
الان على الجواب على سؤالك مع السوشيال
ميديا الان
مفترض الناس يعرفوا قيمه المؤسسات
الاخباريه الموثوقه مثل العربيه او غيرها
هي تقدم معلومات
موثوقه معلومات مؤكده عندنا مصادرنا
الخاصه فينا
ضيوف يطلعون على الشاشه يتكلمون بانفسهم
يعني اتذكر قبلنا مثلا
مسؤول شركه فايزر يعني كلهم تقريبا كل
المسؤول اللقاح اطلعوا وقالوا ردوا على
الشائعات الموضوع لانه ذيك الفتره
المواضيع شائعات اللقاح انتشرت بشكل كبير
على السوشيال ميديا
هذا ايضا يوضح من جهه ثانيه انه المؤسسات
الاعلاميه الكبيره هي اللي تقدم معلومات
دقيقه ومعلومات موثوقه
على السوشيال ميديا المنافسه انا شخصيا
انا احس بالمنافسه ايجابيه دائما يعني
كلمه كبر السوق كلما اعطى حافز
للشخص انه يعمل بشكل
ويتعلم الافكار الجديده لانه انت الاحتكار
دائما مثل السوق السوق الحر اذا انت قفلت
السوق تبدل الاداء يبدا ينزل عندك تدريجيا
دخول لاعبين جدد ودخول عناصر جديده
بالنسبه لنا احنا اتكلم بالنسبه للعربيه
مفيد جدا
بس في اختلاف طبعا بين العمل السوشيال
ميديا وفي
اللاعبين بالسوشيال ميديا الافراد وبينك
عمل المؤسسات كبيره المؤسسات الكبيره تعمل
على مصادر الموثوقه مقابلات مع الشخصيات
كبيره تطلع العربيه او الحدث
تغطيات يعني يعني ما تلقاها اي مكان ثاني
على سبيل المثال واحد اللي هو الزلزال
الاخير زر الاخير ارسلنا تقريبا من اول
يوم اربع مراسلين قدموا تغطيه ممتازه جدا
السوشيال ميديا مثلا يعني المنافسين اذا
ما عندهم الاليات او القدرات يعملوا نفس
الشيء هذا يمكن اكبر من ثالث استاذ ممدوح
على كيف في فتره الزلزال وكل الفيديوهات
والاخبار الحصريه والفيديوهات الحصريه
اللي كانت احنا نحصل عليها من خلال
مراسليننا وكنا طبعا عن طريق شاشتنا وعن
طريق مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وحساباتنا
عليها يمكن هذا كان ابرز مثال على كيف
ممكن الثوره التكنولوجيه تخدم الاعلام
التقليدي صحيح احنا مثلا استثمرنا كثير في
السوشل ميديا عندنا تقريبا اكثر من 200
منصه على السوشيال ميديا الشاشه سلوك
الناس تغير ممكن يشوفك على يشوفك على
الشاشه ممكن الناس يشوفونك على المنصات
على تويتر ولا فيسبوك ولا انستجرام وجودنا
كبير وضخم يعني تطورنا من قبل ثلاث سنوات
كان عندنا 90 مليون متابع الى 180 مليون
متابع فجزء من عملنا اصلا هو التوسع في
منصات التواصل المؤسسه الكبيره مثل
العربيه مثل الحدث عندها قدرات عندها اسم
عندها امكانيات عندها مراسلين عندها
شخصيات تطلع عليها هي اللي يعني تمثل
القوه الاساسيه لهذه المحطات اللاعبين
الاخرين ممكن يعملون اشياء مختلفه يعني
مثلا ممكن لاعب على السوشيال ميديا
المصداقيه ما تعني له شيء كثير ممكن يعمل
تقرير كويس ممكن نقول معلومه غلط ممكن
يقول معلوم مزيفه حكم المشاهدين عليه اخف
من حكمه على العربيه او الحدث بالنسبه لنا
المصداقيه اساسيه بعملنا الموضوعيه اساسيه
نتاكد من الاخبار بشكل اساسي قبل نشرها
عندنا مصادرنا الخاصه هذه يمثل قوه العمل
الصحفي
الحقيقي هم يقولون طبعا الاعلام التقليدي
والعلامه التقليدي شويه هم طبعا الكلمه
شويه مشاغبه يعني فيها تقليل وفيها انتقاص
يعني كانه صبغه سلبيه الاعلام القديم
الممل بس هو مش فعليا مش هذا هو ابدا اكيد
يعني العمل اللي يشتغل صحافه ويعرف صحافه
يعرف لازم ترجع لمصدر اساسي يعني لازم
تقابل الناس المسؤولين لازم تقابل عندك
معلومات حصريه عندك مقابلات حصريه هذا
العمل الصحفي الحقيقي ما تغير من 200 سنه
الى اليوم تغير التكنولوجيا مفيده ادوات
اختلفت عشان كذا انا اقول حتى بالنسبه
للكفاح المعلومات المزيفه كيف تتاكد انه
معلومه مزيفه لازم ترجع انت مصدر اساسي
مثل عربيه مثلا او مثل الحدث او من
المؤسسات المحترمه هذا هو برضه من كيف
تكافح الاخبار المزيفه لكن القضاء عليها
انا اشوفها مستحيل صعب لانه منتشره بكل
مكان
ومع هيك بتلاقي فيه مدرسه كامله بالاعلام
بتتحدث عن انه يعني لم يبقى مكان للاعلام
التقليدي خصوصا لما يتعلق الامر بالجيل
الجديد اللي مهووس بالسوشيال ميديا وحتى
بياخذ كل مصادر اخباره من مواقع على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي او حسابات عليها وهاي
المدرسه بتقول بانه التلفزيون بشكله
التقليدي اللي احنا بنعرفه او يحتضر شو
رايك
بهذا الراي بالنسبه لموضوع التلفزيون هذا
الموضوع دائما مفتوح للنقاش انا بالنسبه
لي انا عندي وجهه نظر بس شوي نحتاج يحتاج
تفصيل للموضوع
وجود التلفزيون في البيوت لا زال موجود
كجهاز في الولايات المتحده 90 بالبيوت في
البيوت الامريكيه عندها عندها تلفزيونات
موجوده في البيت احنا يمكن مئه بالمئه
يعني
ما عندي احصائيه بس اتوقع انه اعلى من 90%
جزء وجود التلفزيون بالبيت شيء شيء
اجتماعي شيء نفسي الناس يجلسون
نفس الوقت ولكن
التعامل مع التلفزيون كجهاز مختلف
نحتاج نفصل بين المحطات الترفيهيه
والمحطات الاخباريه اغلب الناس سلوكهم في
مشاهده المحطات الترفيهيه تغير في السنوات
الاخيره بسبب
ظهور منصات مثل نتفليكس غربيا وشاهد عربيا
يعني سابقا تذكرين الناس كيف واحد يجلس
انت تتابع مسلسل 30 حلقه مثلا في رمضان
هذا السلوك الان خلاص
تغير مع منصات الجديده الان لا يمكن نشوف
حلقات كلها بوقت واحد في المحطات
الترفيهيه غيرت شويه من خطها وهذا ادى ما
راح اقول الى
ما اقول زوالها بس يعني اضعف المحطات
الترفيهيه صار الناس ما يشوفوا محطه
الترفيهيه مثل ما كانوا يشوفون بشكل سابق
ولا تنسين انه مواضيع الديتا المعلومات
عمليه البحث
تطورت مع الذكاء الصناعي فالان الانسان مش
يشوف والله مسلسل تطلع له الى مسلسل يعني
يقرا السلوك المشاهد وهذا ايضا
اسهم في
تطور المنصات على حساب المحطات الترفيهيه
الشيء الثالث اللي هو برضو مهم اللي هو
الان الصراع انا اشوف
على المحتوى
معلومات مثلا في نتفليكس دفعت في 2016
للمحتوى
تطور الان
في 2021 تقريبا دفعوا 17 مليون مليار
دولار للمحتوى فواضح انه فيه في صعود في
الصراع الان على محتوى والناس المحتوى
المحتوى الخاص بهم هو الان الصراع عليه
والناس عندها قبول يعني
سابقا الناس مثلا عندهم نتفليكس الان
عندهم نتفليكس عندهم شاهد وعندهم
ففي واضح سلوك الناس تغير
النقطه هذه برضو تحتاج شويه تفصيل زياده
لانه مع الوقت مع زياده
الاشكاليه وين الناس صار يدفعوا اكثر على
منصات فانا اتصور هذا رايي ممكن يكون صحيح
يكون غلط في المستقبل
يصير عمليه دمج بين المنصات الكبيره هذه
بس على اي حال هذه قوه المنصات اضعفت
المحطات الترفيهيه
المواضيع الاخباريه المواضيع الاخباريه
قصه مختلفه تماما والمحطات الرياضيه لانها
تعتمد على الاخبار العاجله الاخبار
المباشره فالانسان ما يمكن يتابع خبر على
عاجل على منصه هو يحتاج يشوف الخبر الان
موجود على النشره يحتاج يشوف هذا خبر
الزلزال الان ايش صار عدد الضحايا يحتاج
كوفيد معلومات على طول مباشره نفس الشيء
الرياض يحتاج يعرف النتيجه الان في
المباراه مش راح يروح يحضرها بعد ما خلصت
المباراه وعرف النتيجه يرجع يحضر المباراه
مره اخرى
مثل الاخبار مثل الرياضه لا زالت القنوات
الاخباريه ما عندها مشاكل في المستقبل
حاليا في المستقبل مثل ما نشوف الان
المحطات
الترفيهيه في صعود تماما للمنصات انا ما
اقول تلاشي لا بس في ضعف المحطات
الترفيهيه في تجارب على فكره عملوها
للمواضيع السياسيه في المنصات سي ان عملت
ستريمنج بس انه ما مشى لانه الناس عندها
رغبه العاده الناس لا زالت تحب تشوف
الرياضه والسياسه
مباشر والتغطيات اكيد يعني مثلا بتغطيه
الزلزال اللي صار في سوريا وتركيا مؤخرا
يعني غير عن كل اللي كنا نشوفه الفيديوهات
اللي كانت تطلع على السوشيال ميديا مثلا
لمشاهد الزلزال كان كتير مهم بعتقد لكثير
من المشاهدين انه يشوفوا الشيء مباشر لحتى
يعني يضلوا ابديتد وعندهم تحديث على كل
الارقام والاخبار اللي عمالها بتيجي وهذا
بيقودني لسؤال عن موضوع التغطيات بالنسبه
لقناه العربيه انا كعامله هنا من 20 سنه
لاحظت وبشكل واضح انه هناك تغيير نوعا ما
في تغطياتنا تغطيتنا المفتوحه والمطوله
واللي بتستمر لفتره من الزمن شو هي
الاستراتيجيه المختلفه الان فيما يتعلق
بهذه التغطيه والله انا واضحه بصراحه احنا
نلتزم بالعمل الصحفي الحقيقي خلينا نسميه
معلومات مؤكده ارسال مراسلين مناطق ما كنا
نوصلها قبل كذا في اوكرانيا او في طالب او
في افغانستان او اي مكان
ضيوف على مستوى عالي معلومات على مستوى
يعني مؤكده
رؤساء دول يعني قبلنا
هذه جزء اساسي التركيز
من قنوات بالنسبه للقنوات الاخباريه
وبالنسبه للعربيه هو التركيز على اهميه
المحتوى اذا ركزت على اهميه المحتوى
واعطيته قيمه حقيقيه انت عندك قدره على
النجاح صحيح نستفيد من التكنولوجي نستفيد
من الذكاء الاصطناعي بس كل شيء يرجع لشيء
اساسي اللي هو كيف تقدم العمل الصحفي في
اوكرانيا مثلا كنا موجودين قبل قبل الغزو
وقبل الحرب ما تبدا
في طالبان لما حدثت سقوط سقوط كابول كنا
موجودين في في موضوع الزلزال في مواضيع
كثيره
قوه العربيه والحدث بقوه المحتوى الاخباري
الذي اعتقد هذا الجزء الاساسي بالعمل
عندنا القدره عندنا توسع ايضا على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي عندنا مثلا مواد كثيره
موجوده على منصات الاجتماعي نفس الشاشه
كلها يمكن اي شخص وهذا جزء من سلوك الناس
الناس يتوقعوا يشوف العربيه فقط على
الشاشه لا في ناس يشوفوا العربيه على على
تويتر على الفيسبوك يشوفها على الانستجرام
فجزء من استثمارنا هو استثمرنا في
السوشيال ميديا بحيث انه المشاهد مش لازم
يعني
هو يشوفها على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
لما يصير حدث كبير يشوف الشاشه او يدخل
على تويتر او يدخل فيسبوك فهذه قوه
المحتوى الاخباري هو اللي يجذب المشاهدين
لك في اخر في اخر النهار وهذا مثال على
توظيف منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لخدمه
الخبر وخدمه
الشاشه نفسها احنا طبعا على العربيه بلشنا
او بدانا بعدد محدود من الحسابات على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اليوم في عنا
اكثر من 200 حساب وهذا بشكل كبير جدا جزء
اساسي من عملنا اللي هو التوسع على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي يعني احنا عندنا هدفين
اساسيين اللي هو تقويه الشاشه بشكل اساسي
وهذا النعمله يوميا مع الزملاء الاخبار
يوميا اجتماعات كيف قدم الماده ايش
المقابل نعملها كيف نعمل التغطيه عند
الاجتماعات مستمره نفس الشيء احنا ما ننسى
يعني وجود الحضور على منصات تواصل بس
بطريقتنا الخاص يعني استخدمنا واستثمرنا
منصات التواصل بطريقه تناسب العربيه او
تناسب الحدث او تناسب موقع مواقع العربيه
المختلفه فهذا جزء اساسي من اللعبه لما
يصير حدث كبير
حدث مهم حدث ضخم اغلب الناس يجي يشوف لانه
يعني هو يثق بقيمه المحطه فيروح على تويتر
ويروح على فيسبوك يروح على الانستغرام
يروح بالنسبه لي انا كلها هي بنهايه
العربيه كلها يعني في مكان واحد
فجزء من اساسي من استثمار السنوات الماضيه
كان انه يكون حاضرين في كل مكان والحمد
لله نجحنا يعني في ذلك لو رجعنا لموضوع
التغطيات ذكرت حضرتك في البدايه بانه اهم
اشي واللي بميز اي
شاشه او محطه اخباريه خصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالتغطيات هو المحتوى وابرز عوامل هذا
المحتوى هم المراسلين على الارض وفي
الميدان لانه هم اللي بيغنوا هذا المحتوى
وممكن انه ايضا يحصلوا على معلومات وعلى
اخبار حصريه للعربيه مثلا اللي بتابع
العربيه راح يلاحظ كمان بانه شبكه مراسلي
العربيه توسعت بشكل هائل في الفتره
الاخيره في الاعوام الاخيره
هل هذا هو التركيز الان على يعني انه يكون
للعربيه جيش من المراسلين يصل الى كل مكان
اكثر من التركيز على وجود مكاتب في دول
معينه او مناطق معينه
هو وجود المكاتب اساسي بس بالنهايه يعني
هي مكاتب المراسيل المرتبطه بنفس الشيء
توسع اماكن كثيره بسبب للحياه التكلفه
بسبب قوانين دول ما تسمح لك تكون موجود
فيها بس وجود المراسلين بالنهايه هو اللي
يقدم لك الخبر يقدم لك المعلومه يقدم لك
الاشياء الحصريه
وانا حقيقه يعني معجب كثير في شجاعه
المراسلين احيانا يطلبون مني راويه يعني
يروحون اماكن خطيره يغطون وهذا يرجع
للسؤال الاول سؤال سالتيني في البدايه ليش
العربيه ناجحه في ناس بالعربيه
وهذا الثقافه الموجوده ثقافه الشغف وحب
المكان هو يروح اماكن انا يعني واحد يسال
نفسه ليش انت تروح اماكن مثل كذا ليش تروح
اماكن خطيره مستحيل بسبب المال مستحيل
ممكن تاخذ حياتك ليه لانه هو صحفي حقيقي
يحب يقدم صحفي حقيقي وعنده شغف وعنده حب
للمكان هذا جزء اساسي حقيقه من عملنا فانا
احيانا اوقفهم احيانا بصراحه
ليه لانه الصحفي احيانا يكون ما يفكر
بطريقه عقلانيه هو يشوف الخبر ويشوف
التغطيه اهم من سلامه الشخصيه فاحيانا
اوقفهم احيانا نلقى اجراءات معينه
احيانا يعني نحاول نقنعهم بس مش الان
بعدين وحين والله نخليهم بس مع المتابعه
ومع المراقبه ومع بشوف اللي يشتغل صحافه
هذه مين الصحافه وجهه نظري انا اتكلم عن
شكل عام عن اي مهنه ثانيه يعني لما يصير
وباء لما يصير حرب لما يصير الناس بالعاده
تهرب المسؤولين
بالضبط
ما يفكر بسلامه الشخصيه كيف شخص يروح
اماكن
شركات بنوك مؤسسات كبيره كلها يهربون كل
الوظائف الاخرى يهربون منها على فكره الا
الصحفيين
والجيوش تبقى والصحافين يكونوا موجودين هل
دليل على قيمه الكبيره للعمل الصحفي
والعمل الاعلامي بشكل عام بالنسبه للعلم
عندنا عندنا مذيعين عندنا صحفيين عندنا
برضو داخل غرفه الاخبار
يعني وجودهم يسهل عمل اي مدير وانا
الحقيقه اعتبر نفسي محظوظ بالعمل مع كوكبه
ومميزه من الزملاء والزميلات هاي نقطه
مهمه كتير والحقيقه بتقودني لنقطه اخرى
وهي سلامه وامان العاملين في الميدان بما
انه شبكه مراسلين العربيه توسعت بشكل كبير
واحنا عم نغطي
كل انحاء العالم ومرات بكون في بالفعل
احداث خطيره جدا من حروب او مواقف بتكون
خطيره مثل مثلا الزلزال اللي صار في تركيا
وسوريا شو هي استراتيجيه او خطه العربيه
لسلامه زملائنا العاملين في الميدان والله
هذا موضوع جدا مهم في تدريبات خاصه
للصحفيين على مناطق الحروب كيف تتعامل مع
مع الهجمات المفاجئه كيف تتحسس المكان
الاماكن الخطيره كيف يعني جزء من التدريب
المستمر يعود المراسلين على كيف انهم
يتجنبون او ما يتخذون القرارات خاطئه
ونفس الشيء هذا خصوصا نعملها مع المراسلين
اللي في بدايه مشوارهم في عندنا مراسلين
يعني مثل ما قالوا عندهم خبره طويله
تعلموا مع الوقت صاروا مراسلين او مراسلات
حرب فصار عندهم جزء من الثقافه الى ما
يروحون في اوكرانيا
كثير
زميلات وزملائنا دخلوا في مناطق فيها
مواجهات مباشره اتذكر احد الزملاء كان بعد
دقيقه من انتهاء معركه بين الروس
والاوكران كان فيه جثث وكان في معرفه ايش
وكان في خطوره انا يعني انا حريص جدا على
سلامه الموظفين انا ما يمكن ابدا
دائما اقول لهم انا بالنسبه لي سلامتك
الشخصيه قبل كل شيء
فحريصين انه ما حتى لو كان في خبر حصري او
في تغطيه مهمه او فيه نحافظ على سلامه
الموظف ولكن داعيه في صراع بين المدير ولا
المراسلين على لا انا حابب اروح المكان
هذا انا والله لا اشوف ما في مشكله انا
لانه هو مثل ما قلت لك عندهم رغبه دايم
يقدموا شيء جديد شغف كبير مراسله لما يكون
الارض يحب يشوف شيء مختلف فدائما هذا
الصراع موجود ولكن مع التدريبات مع
التعليمات مع التوجيهات نحاول نقلل بخطوره
هذا الموضوع
مواضيع فكريه خصوصا برضه من ادوار العربيه
اللي هو طرح او دعم الافكار المعتدله يعني
مثلا قبل فتره عملنا في الوثائقي عن
المفكر
نصر حامد ابو زيد عملنا عن نجيب محفوظ
عملنا عن اسماء مستنيره لان دورنا برضو ما
نعمل بس فقط سياسيا نعمل فكريا فكريا انه
خطاب المتطرف خطاب الكراهيه خطاب العنف
سيطر على الثقافه العربيه سنوات طويله
دورنا حنا في المحطه دعم الفكر المعتدل
الاسلام الحضاري الاسلام الاخلاقي هذا
يعني من ضمن انا اشوف ادوارنا لتقديم خدمه
للمشاهد العربي لانه في محطات كثيره
حقيقه يعني تشتغل على فكره الغرائز وعلى
فكره العمر
الاشياء الطائفيه بين الدول وبين الشعوب
حتى داخل الدوله الواحده
هذه مضره بشكل كبير جدا
ويعني ومضر على مستوى التعليم على مستوى
الافكار على مستوى التصرفات الناس دول
العربيه لا ايضا عندنا هدف تغطيه سياسيه
بشكل اساسي ولكن عندنا ايضا ادوار فكريه
نفتخر بنقوم فيها
العربيه بدات قبل 20 سنه بمحطه واحده الان
هي مظله تضم تحت جناحها منصات عديده
محطتين اخباريتين
وراديو وبودكاست راح نيجي بالحديث عن
الراديو تحديدا ولكن محطتين اخباريتين
العربيه والحدث شو الفرق بينهم لانه في
كتير ناس ما بتعرف وبنفس الوقت يعني ما هو
جمهور كل منهما على حده
خليني ابدا بالحدث الحدث
قناه قويه
قويه جدا في مناطق الصراعات مناطق
النزاعات
في مناطق مثل اليمن
الحدث مشاهده بشكل كبير ممكن مشاهده اكثر
من العربيه في العراق مثلا حدث مشاهده اي
مناطق تهتم يعني عندها مشاكل سياسيه او
نزاعات او حروب في المنطقه العربيه اتكلم
الحدث تكون هي تعطي ساعات اطول من العربيه
العربيه بحكم انه عندنا مثلا بزنس وعندنا
رياضه وعندنا برامج برامج بشكل عام نعطي
المساحات هذه ولكن نفتح مساحه للحدث تغطي
بشكل اوسع ولكن بشكل عام انا حاب اقول
وجود العربيه وجود الحدث
يعني كم لون بعض انا اعتبر قوه اعلاميه
ضاربه مش موجوده بكل المؤسسات الاعلاميه
الحدث
عند اسماء كبيره عندها مراسلين كبار عندها
صحفيين داخل كبار فعندها قدره على على
التوسع والتمدد والعمل بشكل اساسي في
المناطق هذه نفس الوقت العربيه عنده
القيمه العاليه عندها وهذا اقول العربيه
دائما فيه
قيمه اخباريه عاليه سياسيا بالبيزنس عندنا
اللي هو الاسواق اعلى مستوى الرياضه اعلى
الاقتصاديه على فقيمه العربيه تقدم لك
اعلى مستوى نفس الشيء الحدث تقدمك على
مستوى بس الحدث تركيزها على المناطق اللي
في حروب ونزاعات لانه حدث عندها مساحات
اوسع للتغطيه لكن بشكل عام هم يكملون بعض
وهو قناه كل قناه لها خطها المختلف ولكن
كمؤسسه شبكه العربيه يمثلون لنا قوه ضاربه
ولا تنسين اللي هو المنصاتهم الخاصه فيهم
اها طيب خلينا نحكي الان عن توسع قناه
العربيه حتى اصبحت هذه المظله التي نتحدث
عنها اللي فيها منصات كثيره فيها قناتين
اخباريتين زي ما ذكرنا وراديو على ما يبدو
قريبا والعربيه مهم جدا نتحدث عن العربيه
لانه شاهدتنا مجروحه يعني في
البودكاست الراديو قريبا راح نطلق واحنا
سعيدين الحقيقه انه الراديو اول مره
العربيه راديو في اف ام عربيه اف ام ستطلق
من الرياض
خلال ايام اذاعه اخباريه فيها برامج فيها
نشرات اخبار لانه نعتقد انه المشاهد
المحب للاذاعه الناس اللي في سياراتهم
يسمعوني يحبوا يسمعوا اوكي يحبوا يسمعوا
اغاني ويحبوا اسماء اشهر ترفيه ولكن فيه
اهتمام للناس برضو يسمعوا اخر اخبار
العاجله اخر المعلومات ايش صاير في
اوكرانيا ايش صاير فيه افغانستان ايش صار
في كل مكان العربيه راح تقدم لهم الخدمه
هذه بشكل اساسي معلومات موثوقه معلومات
مؤكده فالناس ممكن
يصير عندهم الرغبه الكبيره بيسمعوا ويصير
عندهم معلومات نقول
يعني تحديثيه او معلومات مستمره طول الوقت
بالنسبه للبودكاست احنا بقى لنا سنتين
اطلقنا من وصفه البودكاست الخاصه فينا من
سنتين صراحه من اهم المنصات اللي اطلقناها
في في العميل الماضيه
السنه هذه راح نتوسع فيها اكبر
من ضمن ايضا خطه نتوسعنا
السوشيال ميديا توسعنا في بالاذاعه الان
جزء من اساسي من عملنا البودكاست مثل
برنامج كي راويه
يعني كلام منطقي وبرامج كثيره ولكن انا
اعتقد البودكاست الان صار من ضمن الاشياء
الاساسيه في الاعلام ضروري بالنسبه لنا
انه نعمل فيه بشكل كبير السنه هذه برضو
راح يكون تركيزنا اكبر على البودكاست كيف
ننميه كيف نطوره كيف نعمل نعمل شكل اكبر
فهذه هذا الجزء اساسي
مختلفه تماما عن المحطات الاخباريه شغلنا
كم اخباريه لكن جزء اساسي من عملنا ايضا
اللي هو استغل الفرص كل الفرص الموجوده
المشهد الاعلامي بالفتره الاخيره تغير في
السنوات الاخيره ليس فقط انه مع الثوره
الرقميه ولكن حتى محطات جديده ايضا ظهرت
على الساحه الاعلاميه في حتى الاشهر
الاخيره الماضيه وبنفس الوقت في منصات
رقميه جديده اخباريه تظهر وستظهر هل انت
مطمئن على قدره العربيه على المنافسه مثل
ما قلت لك انا بشكل منافسه بشكل عام موضوع
كويس يعني موضوع جيد انه يصير عندك دخول
لاعبين جدود الاعلام انا قلت لك قبل كذا
انا ضد فكره الاحتكار هو مش نادي مغلق انت
تمسك الباب تقفل وخلاص يعني لا الاعلام
طبيعته منفتح عشان كذا يصير عندك سوق كبير
بالسوق الاعلامي صح ممكن تستقبل صحفيه
ممكن تستقبل كتاب ممكن تستقطب وجوه جديده
فكل ما زاد كل ما زاد المنصات
والمحطات انا مفيد لك كمحطه
بالنسبه لنا وجود يعني اسم العربيه اسم
قوي جدا
كبراند قوي جدا
كمحتوى قوي جدا
عدد نوعيه
الموظفين عندنا نوعيه الزميلات والزملاء
على اعلى مستوى المهني واحترافيه انا مش
قلق حقيقه على مستقبل ولكن انا اقول دائما
الزملاء
الناس الفاشلين دايم اللي هم ما يعيشون
على الامجاد حنا العربيه ثاني يوم
الاحتفال العربيه 20 سنه خلاص انتهى
بالنسبه لنا
فتركيز على المحتوى تركيز على اختيار
الناس على مستوى
وظيفي وعلى مستوى اخلاقي جزء من اساسي من
العمل
فتح مساحه جديده الاستثمار السوشيال ميديا
استثمار في البودكاست استقطاب اسماء
ومواهب جديده هذه خلي المحطات اللي عندها
حضور اساسي تتطور بشكل اكبر ولكن الركوع
للماضي والعيش على الامجاد القديمه
واخلاء الخلل الاداري حين يكون في مشكله
بالخلا الاداري ثقافه العمل تتغير هنا وين
تتاثر
وضعنا ممتاز حقيقه
وراح نكمل فيه ان شاء الله قبل ما انهي
معك استاذ ممدوح بنضل انه اسال على موضوع
الانتقال للرياض طبعا العربيه اعلنت من
فتره بانه هناك نيه للانتقال بشكل كامل
لقناه العربيه والعاملين فيها للرياض
وبالفعل بدا جزء من هذا الانتقال يتم
واحنا هلا عنا حوالي سبع ساعات بث من بث
قناه العربيه يتم بثه من الرياض وين وصلت
الجهود وما اهميه الانتقال الى الرياض في
هذه المرحله بالذات من حياه العربيه
الرياض تعرفين الرياض من اهم العواصم
حاليا
اقتصاديا وسياسيا وجودنا في الرياض
بشكل
سينعكس
قيمه الرياض على عملنا بشكل كبير جدا مثل
الخطوه لنا للنمو بشكل اكبر
توسع بشكل اكبر فخطوه كبيره كبيره جدا
بدانا مثل ما بدانا فعلا بالانتقال
وسننتقل بشكل كامل لكنها فرصه كبيره
واضافه كبيره للعربيه شركه العربيه بشكل
كامل الحقيقه الحديث معك لا يمال استاذ
ممدوح شكرا كتير على هذه الدردشه اللطيفه
بتمنى انه نكون قدرنا انه نلقي الضوء على
جانب لم يعتد عليه المشاهد من قناه
العربيه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معنا مدير عام
قناه العربيه الاستاذ ممدوح المهيني شكرا
الشكر
[موسيقى]